oh hey what everybody so apparently
everybody was talking about this before
and some other people have done it
they're licking toilets they're licking
their licking stuff dude it's it's it's
the same thing as when those people were
drinking mouthwash and spitting it back
up these people are insane
they just uh they just want to be some
someone that's they want to be a
sub-link now she's a toilet someone
she's toilet toilet girl from now on the
the woman what's your superpower we
licked the toilet well be known as
toilet girl I lick the toilet and that's
like that's my superpower that's all it
is
she's toilet toilet girl congratulations
you like to toilet mm-hmm now you are
totally girl okay all right let's refill
it's it's uh hey how's it going if you
want to have us read your comments go in
the super chat and super chat stuff and
we will read the stuff that you type and
if you want to help support the show and
become a member get access to the
full-length podcast you've ever missed
the live stream click the join button
down below or go to youtube.com slash
Tim cast IRL slash join and we got up we
had a bunch of stories the Olympics are
canceled the environment is getting
better and if the apocalypse yep there's
a whole bunch of apocalyptic anger thing
and I thought it'd be fun to pull him up
so apparently some lady predicted this
like 20 years ago oh yeah she said in
2020 a pneumonia would spread yeah she
wrote in a book and you know it's like
Nostradamus you make a million
predictions one of them comes right
everyone thinks it's true but but
there's also locust swarms in Malta in
different parts of the the world right
now signs of the Apocalypse yeah and the
apocalypse is here but the first door
we're gonna get to his toilet girl
totally like girl so actually before I
do that I gotta give a shout out to this
Kickstarter for Snow White zombie
apocalypse so I'll tell you a quick
story while we're getting started this
is from a dude named Brett Brent L'Engle
and he is a lefty dude on Facebook I
argue with all the time but he's a cool
dude and we get into funny arguments and
so he wrote this comic called snow white
zombie apocalypse where Snow White
awakens dun dun dun 28 days later and is
funny so he and I ended up I ended up
buying one of his comics and I liked it
and so I told him out I actually am one
of the people who kicked you know the
the Kickstarter for him
and so I'm just giving a shout out you
guys check it out snow white zombie
apocalypse on Kickstarter for interested
in checking out his thing I think it's
cool like one of the main reasons I
really wanted to do it is because you
know I argue with people all the line
all the time on the internet and it's
sometimes especially now with how crazy
everything's gotten with like the world
on fire you know it's it's important to
focus on what we agree on and what we
like and you know I don't know zombie
apocalypse stuff is fun yeah
particularly now I don't know so you
know I'll get my shout out and I think
it's cool I think there's a cool comic
it was fun so this is gonna be for the
sequel so if you're interested you can
check it out but let's jump over to the
first story about this toilet girl
toilet the story is uh strangely this is
from I don't know what global news this
is the Chinese propaganda website or
something oh no this is the Canadian
website oh wait maybe it is the
propaganda website I don't know well I
mean there's not much propaganda in here
how are you gonna spin this on tik-tok
star no okay films herself licking
airplane toilet dishes stars that as I'm
saying actually a tick-tock star if you
know she should get a toilet lid on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame boil a toilet lid
toilet bowl named after so well let's
let's let's see there you go the
coronavirus challenge she is in goodness
she is indeed licking a toilet that's
like full lick - that's not just like
the tip of the tongue that's like from
side to side you know it's funny about
it though full-on lick man she's she's
obviously embarrassed about it because
she posted to her Twitter mm-hmm so this
is the original video and she didn't get
that much attention it's like dude you
licked a toilet seat for 580 thousand
views like there are people who film
their dog getting belly rubs who get
more views than that I know it's and
you're like oh like a toilet seat so the
funny thing is this this woman
apparently she like posted this video
okay in it so I it's so obvious she's
really embarrassed to buy it oh really
but it's see it seems like she's trying
to play it off Artemi trolling
international news SK SK whatever nah
when you watch it she's like it was my
sugar daddy's airplane and it was clean
and I don't like old people so that's
why I did it and it's like that make any
sense
oh dude wouldn't she get the coronavirus
if if that was the case
like dude old person or not you're the
one licking the toilet seat if you don't
like someone then lick the toilet so
wait but here's the thing
she trot like she tries justifying
licking the toilet by saying it was a
private airplane toilet oh sure it's
like way way hold on I thought you would
have said I cleaned it first I feel like
it was a private plane I'm like that
doesn't make it better so there was only
like four people that used it yeah
you're looking a busser the other
handful of people
I mean maybe she's into looking butts
anyway she's not the only one like you
know whatever some people are into that
what generation I did what what about
somebody who licked like a public did it
catch on yeah I'm just curious like were
they were there a bunch of other people
licking toilets oh my god you know what
man these people my good toilet boy
toilet boy and toilet girl here's the
thing that they want the attention now
here's the thing this guy this this guy
really does want the attention
yeah he's all about it because he's done
a bunch of stuff he's done a bunch of
things like this before it's his thing
okay he is it his whole bit is being
like I don't know a pathetic loser I'm
not saying that to insult him I'm saying
like it's his bit like oh he does these
things okay okay so cuz then after this
he's in the hospital like oh no now I
have the virus like he's trying to play
it up like he's a loser ting it clicks
and traffic did a fake video that he had
the virus and well hospital bed or
something
he was it he made a really short video
that looks like he's in a hospital bed
oh my goodness because he's he so here's
the thing right if that chick who licked
the toilet ended up testing positive for
corona virus everyone make fun of her
yeah trying to get made fun of that's
why I'm red isn't even talked about this
guy yeah right because they know it's
it's not true the funny thing is so this
is like a public restroom toilet and
apparently he got he got banned for it
oh well good yeah they're same out here
who was part of that Ava Louise toilet
seat looking I'm sorry it's toilet
toilet girl let's see looking at Ray oh
man dude from now on whenever like if
she ever does anything she's toilet girl
yeah totally
I mean I never er I've never even heard
of this person before now it's just too
hot girl but why would I want to
remember a name true you know she's
toilet girl cuz you know I'm I see if
res I'll buy oh you're the toilet girl
oh you're the person who's like toilet
yeah that that's disgusting you're
disgusting oh girl well that's a chance
for the rest of her life could you
imagine that
I mean kind of thing I could imagine it
but I don't want to because she's like
she's just some dumb young person and
she was like she think about it I feel
bad because it's it's it's so it's so
it's pitiful yeah you know I mean like I
don't know no pathetic is kind of harsh
it's pitiful mmm like that's how how
much of a loser she is that's how how
desperate she is for attention yeah like
she has nothing going for and she's like
please love me that's something like
it's it makes me feel sad for her you
know like I don't even cringe like
almost makes me four inched no but I
mean I get it but it makes me no no
cringe cringe is when you feel
embarrassment for someone else was it
what is it when you feel depression for
someone else there's a term like the
opposite of shedding Freud schadenfreude
opposite of that yeah there's now I
imagine like what was going through her
mind when she was like the only way
people will really care about me as if I
lick this toilet like I don't know maybe
yeah but like she's trying to come off
Bach she's altough like but it was a
private plane it's like man I'm getting
rid of the furniture so people can don't
have to look at it anymore well no wait
there's more buddy I don't want to see
it oh here you go this is fine yeah
moving on I'm nasty moths ever and then
play the video says go to the helicopter
play the video please
what is it is it deodorant
yeah what smooth move I'm pretty sure
what he's doing is illegal actually yeah
I think so definitely yeah yet proc
tampering yeah yeah and then and they're
filming their faces yeah this is how
desperate they are on their own so you
know you know it's funny I kind of
thought about something you see how
insane this is like actually let's go
back well I don't want to show the video
of toilet girl again but but think about
how sad and pathetic you have to be to
like a toilet seat yeah I was realizing
I realized this like the political
discourse on Twitter is the political
equivalent of looking at toilet seats
okay so yeah but but think about it like
she was like if I like this people will
give me attention yeah and so people
wasn't even that much attention right I
mean she I mean we're talking about it
but then yeah we're making fun of her
though but then think about you know the
politics on Twitter yeah it's it's the
word version of licking a toilet seat
screeching like everyone's racist or a
bigot no orange man bad and all that
stuff it's like how can I lick a toilet
seat but say words so I call it word
vomit word vomit yeah yeah but just
basically like yeah yeah I considered
the Twitter the Wild West of the human
brain very nice way of saying that I
mean it kind of is but it's actually
it's I think it's different what imagine
if you were able to cherry pick all of
the toilet toilet girls out of the
country and put them on top and put a
camera on them
that's Twitter I'd like to think that
not everyone on Twitter because why am I
on Twitter no no here's the thing
well I had somebody ask me how do you
get so many followers on Twitter and I
was like oh look a toilet no okay I
guess well she did get any followers
from oh no she didn't right yeah here's
what I did
here's what I do here's appears might
here's my here's my secret to getting
Twitter followers I'll be like sitting
around and I'll have a thought and I'll
pop Twitter and I'll type it out send it
and turn the phone off
I don't look I don't interact with
people mmm throughout the day I'll have
Twitter open and I'm okay but my Twitter
feed is mostly news personalities right
okay so it's news organizations and
journalists and the people who follow me
are more political I don't check my
mentions you know so I literally open
the app send out a shower thought then
I'm done
ceasing on the news and I'll be like oh
and I'll send it and then of course
people go in tart screeching like
banshees and my replies but I just I
don't care I know so there are a lot of
people who lick toilet seats thinking
they'll get followers from it
she didn't or licking products and uh
yeah they're not gonna get they're not
gonna get files right this dude who
licked the other ìlook toilet got banned
yeah he didn't have any traffic enemy
likes he got like 500 likes and people
were like imagine being this much of a
loser the only thing is this dude is
like this this guy who looked a toilet
and got banned he's trying to be a loser
you know I mean I don't like is there a
personality that was like that somebody
who was purposefully trying to put on a
character that was like pathetic Rodney
Dangerfield yeah he was like dumped on
himself yeah but it's different itself
Debra this guy was trying to so when
Rodney Dangerfield would say like you
know I get no respect around here laughs
because he's joking he's a famous
comedian right okay this dude licked a
toilet then pretended he got really sick
then got banned that's what he was going
for mmm
he wants people to laugh at him it's
like exhibitionist or something yeah
what does it call him people have like a
fetish for humility that would be milli
Asian that's what he's into our guys on
jackass subjugation but they're I think
what the guys on jackass is that yes
they're like I can't Nate I'm trying to
think of anyone that is this low that's
that's already famous but I don't know
the thing about the Jackass guys was you
could call them losers whatever but they
were laughing and having a good time
and we're choosing to do these things
yeah this guy was like I looked at why
look at me oh no no I'm sick Oh God and
so the reason why I think he's going for
that is because you'd most people would
be like haha he got the virus that shows
him right trying to lick toilets yeah he
was he's probably faking it you know
he's trying to convince people someone
someone wrote Tom Green weird about Tom
Green yeah very bad Tom Green was he's
not gross he was but he was assertive
okay like he were do you mean by that if
Tom Green did something and then his
show got canceled yeah then I'd be alive
oh wow okay if like he was pretending
like his show got canceled well I guess
he probably had cancer didn't he do that
I don't know yeah
maybe I wouldn't know but I can't see
that no but that's a victim there's that
that's not being a loser
yeah like toilet girls a loser yeah like
yeah yeah like she looked at oh and then
she was like oh no I mean like what - I
don't like old people that's the reason
I did it it was it was a private plane
like a private plane still like the
toilet - thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you